All right, welcome back to,
Computer Vision.
Today what we're going to do is,
we're going to, finish up,
particle filter, particle filtering and
we're going to do,
sort of do particle filtering for real.
We mostly enter, discussed it from
an algorithmic perspective and
sort of how it maintains
density estimate.
And we even looked at some robot
vision examples last time.
You know, localization through
the Smithsonian and, and other things.
And this time, we'll talk a little
bit about real vision and
how you might do it.
So if you remember this
Bayesian filter framework.
We had to have sort of four
different elements, right?
We needed a prior,
which nobody ever talks about.
It's kind of the black
sheep of the family.
A dynamical model or
an action model that says how we think
things change from moment to moment,
based upon where they were and
the inputs that are provided.
A sensor model, the likelihood
of a measurement given a state.
And then we have this
stream of observations, and
the question is what to do with them?